Let's look at other 2D
image transformations.
Again, let's look at this simple
equation that we're looking at.
Let's say I create
the simple equation here,
which basically takes a scale in x and
y directions, Sx and Sy.
And basically what that means is
that this image now would be scaled.
But the parameters Sx and Sy and
they would of course be scaled around
the origin point of the image, 0 and 0.
I mean, there would be a linear
scaling in that direction.
Here is an interesting transformation,
M matrix.
What would happen when I applied this?
If you think about it,
basically what it's going to do,
it's going to flip
the image in one direction.
So basically, what it's going to do is,
when I have the y-axis going this way,
it's going to flip all of
the values on the, this side.
That is the right side of the image,
to the left and
all the left ones to the right.
So basically,
that'll be a mirror operation.
If I put minus 1 on both of them, that
would be a mirror over the origin, so
basically it will flip both an x,
axis and
the y-axis to generate
a mirror flipped image.
Here is another interesting one which
basically now I put the terms on the two
off diagonal terms, and
we would refer to this as shear, so
shear in x and shear in y would give
us and image that would be sheared.
That basically would kind of have
the impact of kind of having top row of
the image,
kind of move towards the left.
And, I'm sorry, top part of the image
moving towards to the right and
bottom moving to the left.
We'll show examples of that in a bit,
too.